plus de 3 milliards de personnes sont
confinées soit la moitié de la
population mondiale si l'europe est
aujourd'hui l'épicentre de la pandémie
due nouveau coronavirus des pays du
monde entier sur les traces de la chine
ont décidé d'un profil mans total tour
d'horizon en images
[Musique]
avant quand cette maladie n'était pas là
nous étions tous heureux tout le monde
il y avait beaucoup de bateaux beaucoup
de gens mais maintenant nous ne pouvons
rien faire à cause de cette maladie
nous devons garder nos distances et ce1
avec les autres
[Musique]
c'est une catastrophe planétaire qui a
mené un confinement général donc c'est
normal que la place tahir soient vides
ou presque entièrement vide ceux qui
sont là sont peu nombreux c'est vrai
mais ils sont là pour que notre cause
perdure
non
[Musique]
c'est un peu sinistre ici en ce moment
c'est généralement très fréquentée par
les touristes
c'est une de nos saisons les plus
chargés donc être ici et il n'y a qu'une
poignée de personnes dont moi même c'est
calme c'est un peu isolé en ce moment